22 caskets holding the bodies of men
women and children
lined up for mars
their families grieve to wonder how long
nigerians will have to endure the
bloodshed
religious leaders say
the government is failing the people
what does it take for every state to
have state police to be able to present
this why why do we have to beg
how why do we have to kneel down to beg
anybody
for state police for goodness sake
as the country continues to bleed some
political leaders are beginning to own
up
i
am here
before you to accept
our failure
on security
we are failed
we are filled
the service brought together people of
different faiths in anger and grief
the physical damage caused by the older
church attack may heal quicker but
community leaders here say they expect
the psychological impact to last much
longer what happened here has shaken the
peace and confidence of a region that
has largely avoided much of the violence
that is sweeping across nigeria raising
fears that no place is safe in africa's
most populous nation
a few kilometers from the funeral mars
the olympia days bury the family
matriarch
one of the victims of the church
massacre
[Music]
it was
it was
a big shock
looking at my mom
somebody
this was a friend
lying lifeless no life
somebody spoke to two days before the
incident
saint francis church while the attack
happened is cold enough
inside
some of the debris have been cleared
but the blood stained ceiling is a
graphic reminder of the carnage that
took place here on june the fifth
and that attack has renewed concerns
about safety of lives in the entire
country with less than a year to general
elections
al jazeera orwa southwest nigeria